[Musique]
c'est ton droit c'est korogo le plus
gros bidonville de nairobie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un amant seulement chaotique de cabane
d'habitation de fortune plantée tout
autour d'un énorme dépotoir un lieu de
vie pour près de 200 000 personnes comme
Elvis hottiano
[Musique]
c'est aussi le siège d'un orchestre pas
comme les autres
ghetto classique Orchestra former
entièrement de jeunes
issus du bidonville un ensemble musical
mais aussi et d'abord une école
c'est ici qu'elle vis à tout appris un
amour et une passion pour la musique
qu'il transmette à son tour à des jeunes
qui entoure
des jeunes comme Melvin ne tienneau et
ça me demande qui avec le solfège c'est
tout un univers qui s'ouvrage
[Rires]
avec la musique les jeunes apprennent la
rigueur la routine le dur labeur aussi
que représente les répétitions dans des
conditions loin d'être idéales car
l'orchestre s'est installé là où vivent
ces élèves en bordure du plus gros
dépotoir de l'Est africain constamment
exposés à des fûts détoxiques
[Musique]
un contexte difficile qui a forgé la
détermination de sa me demande Guy 14
ans son instrument est devenu une
passion une obsession
[Musique]
autrefois décrocheur il est toujours dû
un élève modèle depuis qu'il s'est mis à
la clarinette Simon s'est transformé
même sa mère ne le reconnaît plus
aujourd'hui c'est avec enthousiasme que
Simon se lève tous les matins et qu'il
traverse le bidonville de korhogocho
pour se rendre à l'école est différent à
la saleté à la pauvreté qui l'entoure
portée par l'ambition et le reste
[Musique]
et toute la semaine il attend avec
impatience le dimanche
[Applaudissements]
le jour où il retrouve ses amis de
l'orchestre du ghetto pour jouer
ensemble
l'orchestre c'est déjà produit à
l'étranger a déjà joué pour le pape et
pour Barack Obama
le but de ghetto Classics n'est
clairement pas de faire de tous ces
élèves des musiciens professionnels
[Musique]
musique et d'abord ici un outil un moyen
d'élargir les horizons de montrer que
tout un monde existe en dehors du ghetto
et qu'une autre vie est possible
[Musique]
depuis 5 fondation en 2008 l'institution
a formé plus de 2000 élèves dont
certains comme Elvis on en fait une
carrière mais l'un des plus importants
accomplissements de ghetto Classics
c'est d'avoir redonné aux jeunes du
bidonville le droit de rêver et surtout
de leur avoir prouvé que les rêves
peuvent se réaliser